Hi.
I'm Garrick Aden-Buie, a Data
Science Educator at RStudio
and an R and Shiny developer.
I also tinker with
web development,
and I realized that I've learned
the most about web development
by working on my slides.
Wanting to put images
in the right place
or give text the
right color, it's
like each slide ends up
becoming a small web project.
And I've learned more about
web development this way
than any other.
So that's what I want
to share with you today.
How can we use xaringan
as a playground
to learn web development?
So wait, what?
What is xaringan?
First of all, it's in R package
that you can install from CRAN.
Second, it's a way to
write in R Markdown
with some extra syntax, and
then have your R Markdown, R
code, and outputs, plots,
widgets all rendered
into slides.
The slides are
web pages in HTML.
And the great
thing about that is
that you can CSS to layout
and style your slides.
But the downside
is that you have
to use CSS to layout
and style your slides.
So CSS is a little tricky
to wrap your mind around,
but I think that xaringan
makes it a little more fun.
So let's first learn a little
bit about CSS and the web.
CSS styles are rules about
how elements on the screen
should appear.
The most common way to
link a rule to an element
is to use a class.
In CSS, these start with a dot.
Xaringan has an
extra little syntax
that makes it easier to
reference the CSS classes.
You write the class name,
then a pair of brackets,
and then you put
text or whatever
you want inside the brackets.
Here we use the complement
class for the whole sentence
and the rstudio-blue class
for just the word RStudio.
Inside a rule, there
are CSS properties
where you can set a
property equal to a value
like font family to
monospace or color to tomato.
Notice that because rstudio-blue
has its own color,
and it's closer to
the word RStudio,
it wraps around RStudio.
It doesn't turn tomato.
The second thing to
know about the web
is that everything is in
a box. The block boxes
take a full line of
horizontal space.
In Markdown, their brackets
spend more than one line.
Inline boxes fit
within block boxes,
and don't break the flow.
In Markdown, their brackets
are on the same line
like with .rstudio-blue.
The real reason xaringan is so
fun is infinite moon reader,
let me show you why.
OK, I have a little project
here with some slides.
It's an RMD file,
and I've cleared
out all of the starter text.
So let's add a heading,
and render the slides.
Great!
But now let's use
infinite moon reader.
It's available under
the Addins menu.
When we run it, it first
renders the slides.
But when I type, my text
shows up right away.
This is awesome.
So let's recreate the
example we saw in the slides.
I have a compliment
that RStudio is cool,
and I'll put RStudio
in rstudio-blue.
OK, that takes care
of the Markdown.
But we can add HTML to the
slides too, which means
I can create a style block.
And create rules
for the compliment
in rstudio-blue color.
Look, the slides
are updated live.
Are we having fun?
Classes are reusable, so
let's make fun blue too.
OK, one more example.
Let's create a black
element called cat box.
In the box, we'll put a cat.
It's hard to see
the black element,
so let's give it a
background color.
Now you can see it
takes up the whole line,
and let's give it a height and
a width say 300 pixels each.
Rather than have it be
a blue background, let's
actually put a cat in the box.
For this, we can use
background-image with url(),
and then a URL to a
placeholder kitten image.
Now, usually cats on
slides are positioned off
to the side a bit, and
we can do this too.
We'll set position
to absolute, which
tells the browser to put the box
exactly where we want it to be
relative to the top, right,
bottom, or left of the box's
container, which is our slide.
So let's put it about 50 pixels
from the bottom and 50 pixels
from the right.
Great!
One last note. When you're done,
you should put these styles
in a CSS file.
OK, I hope you enjoyed
this and learned a little.
Go explore and have fun.
And also, check
out xaringanExtra,
it's an R package that
brings lots of little goodies
to xaringan.
Go make great slides.